Aliens are coming. They're living among
us. And now it's not coming from the
conspiracy theorist. It's coming from
Harvard scientists. So, we're actually
going to look. He's saying that there is
a meteor, what looks like a comet the
size of Manhattan, but they're saying,
you know what, it doesn't look natural.
It actually looks artificial, like it
could be an alien race in disguise on
their way because the way it moves is
not normal either. So, they're saying
this could very well be a hostile alien
inside of a fake comet moving towards
Earth uh in in a way that we we won't
expect them like a Trojan horse,
but they're expected to be here in
November. I don't know how in the world
people aren't seeing that this is total
a total scop that this is all setting
the stage. How can you predict the month
that some hostile aliens are coming
because you see something through a
telescope. This is in this is just
insane. But check this out. We're going
to we're going to hear from the straight
from the horse's mouth.
>> For the first time ever in Fox 10 talks
history, I believe correct me if I am
wrong. We have a Harvard professor here
to talk to us about some pretty cool
stuff. Avi, thank you for joining us.
His research has been pretty
groundbreaking. Of course, 2017 there
was, I believe, AI, please correct me,
but the first interstellar object uh
that was confirmed uh AmuA Mua uh that
of course had the scientific community
very chatting about what could that be.
But there's a new object that was
discovered July 1st, 31 atlas it is
called, and it's the size of Manhattan,
7 miles across, right? uh hurling
towards space in your theory I know in a
paper talking about what the
possibilities could be
>> right so I you know we are often
frustrated by what happens here on earth
and I'm trying to say let's look up and
maybe we'll have some uplifting news uh
and as soon as it was discovered on the
1 of
>> I do want to interject he said let's
look up and maybe we'll see some
uplifting news you know that's because
we need to be looking up to Jesus but
instead he's saying you You know what?
Maybe aliens could come and help us.
This is a grand illusion. This is Satan.
He's going to manifest as visitants from
other worlds, as the cosmic savior
during a time of great catastrophe.
We're living in it now. Remember, the
counterfeit comes before the true. And
Christ isn't going to touch the ground
when he comes. We're going to be caught
up to meet the Lord in the air. So, do
not fall for this deception no matter
what. This is Satan in disguise. But let
me let him talk. July 2025. I realize
that it must be quite big as you pointed
out and if it's a rock, it's just too
big to be real because uh there is not
enough material in interstellar space to
deliver a rock of that size. But then I
realized in a paper that I wrote with
two colleagues uh that in fact it's
moving on a very special trajectory.
it's a aligned with the orbit of the
Earth around the Sun. There is a special
plane that it's aligned with. The chance
for that happening at random is 0.2%.
So, they're saying like this is not
moving natural at all. Like 0.2% that
this could even possibly be just natural
movements in outer space. All right. I I
man I just wish I could spend like hours
on here just talking about what I think
about space uh where this agenda is
going why these things are important why
it's understand to why it's important to
understand the Bible what the Bible says
about where we live everything is so
important because Satan doesn't just
come up with these deceptions
um to just kind of confuse you a little
bit or cause division or controversy. It
all ties in together. It's all perfectly
knit together for the one grand
deception, the one final deception,
Satan's final opus. And the question is,
was this trajectory designed? Uh because
the chance of it having all these
coincidences is really small. We will
find out. If in the coming month or two
it doesn't look like a comet, doesn't
have a plume of dust and gas around it,
I would start getting worried.
Professor, I mean, so many things go
through my mind. So, so we're saying
there may be a possibility that there's
intelligent life moving this object our
way. I remember being in college and
first hearing someone a professor say,
you know, it's pretty um it's it's it's
pretty arrogant for us to think that we
are the only living creatures in the
universe. What what are your thoughts on
uh other beings being out there and then
being able to get to our solar system to
check us out? But I mean is is that
completely science fiction in your mind
or or maybe not so much?
>> See this is something that we have been
fed through the the school systems the
propaganda. We are forced to go into
indoctrination camps. Just like shatter
Meshach and Abednego and Daniel were
taken into the schools of Babylon and
trained. We're the same way. you if you
do not go to school, the government will
knock on your parents' door and lock
them up or take you to school or
whatever. You have to be trained
according to the books. And so people
would say, why would they lie about this
or that? Well, do you believe in
evolution? because it's being taught to
your children in school that uh earth
was formed 6 million years ago that um
there was a big bang explosion from
nothingness the size something the size
of a period on this page blew up for
some reason caused this perfect
everexpanding universe and that's why
people have the mindset that oh it's
arrogant to think that we're alone out
here there has to be man people didn't
have this mindset even in the 50s
I saw a interview of a guy going on the
street in the black and white days. He
was asking people, "Do you believe in
aliens?" And they're like, "No, that's
science fiction stuff." I personally
have been downtown, asked people on the
street, and 99.9%
of everyone I asked said, "Yes, there
has to be alien life out there because
it's arrogant to think that we're alone
in the universe." That's that's the same
answer every time. This universe is so
vast. It's arrogant to think that earth
is the only one to have spawned life.
And this is coming from the mouths of
even Christians. I would ask them, are
you a Christian? We live in the Bible
belt. This is the south. Most of them
were. And this is the mindset. This is
how Satan has deceived us. But let me
let him talk. Most stars in the Milky
Way galaxy formed billions of years
before the sun. Now you may ask where
will Voyager the spacecraft that we
launched out of the solar system where
will it be in a billion years?
>> If you started the clock billions of
years notice he's saying billions of
years. His mindset is that we've been
out here for billions of years. He's
saying that these aliens may have
existed millions of years before human
life and that's why they're so highly
advanced, right? Well, maybe they're
actually fallen angels and they're
actually, you know, created higher than
humanity and that's why they seem really
smart because Satan is an angel of light
and he can actually put deception in
your mind just like angels actually came
down to Daniel and gave Daniel a vision.
Angels have the power to give you a
vision. That's why people astral project
out of their body. That's how they have
uh when they meditate, they actually
have encounters with
ascended masters and communicate with
them. Right? This is all a delusion.
This is all a hallucination that Satan,
a beautiful angel of light, has the
power to do to humanity. But this is the
mindset that, oh, these these aliens,
they're far more advanced than us. We
humans are nothing in comparison to
these demons out in outer space that are
coming to Earth. years before it started
on Earth. There was plenty of time for
their technological gadgets to reach us.
And we had only one century of science
since quantum mechanics was discovered.
Only one century. They may have had the
benefit of millennia or even millions of
years or maybe even billions of years of
knowing much more about technology and
science. And so we shouldn't assume
anything. You know, you know, in the
past we worried about existential
threats from artificial intelligence,
from uh the change of the climate or
from an asteroid that will impact the
earth. But there is another item that we
should add to the list which is alien
tech.
>> Can you talk about those possibilities?
>> Right. There are two possibilities that
bracket the range of everything that
could happen. They are either friendly
or hostile.
>> And we should be careful because you
know as we know from the story that of
the Trojan horse, they may look friendly
but then there would be something else
behind their intent to visit us. And of
course there should be an organization
that discusses how to respond to that
because we are dealing with a a visitor
that comes to our backyard. It's not a
radio signal from thousands of light
years away where we have plenty of time
to think about how to respond. Here you
have a visitor. You have to decide what
the intent of the visitor is. And you
know it could be a threat to the future
of humanity. Uh so we need policy
makers. We need also psychologist that
will communicate the message to the
public without creating any panic. My
hope is similar to President Rean's
hope. uh that it will bring people
together when there is an external
threat of that nature.
>> If you're not familiar with what he's
talking about, but Ronald Reagan gave a
speech at the United Nations. And he
said, "How quickly all our differences
would just vanish if we were threatened
by an alien race coming to this earth."
And he said, "We're all children of God
and all this stuff." We know
prophetically and just anyone who's had
an awakening about what's going on in
the world, conspiracy theories, whatever
you want to call it, we know that there
is a coming new world order, a coming
one world religion, an antichrist beast
system. How are they going to do that?
How are they going to unite humanity in
a one world government or religion?
Right? And Reagan was saying, "Oh, if
there were an alien threat, all our
differences would be set aside and we'd
unite together." And here it is. Here it
is. We're actually living in the year
that they're predicting that an alien
race is going to come to Earth. Are you
ready for what's about to come for the
uniting of the one world order?
But it could also create a lot of chaos
because the people will feel that
they're not protected by the government.
The question is whether they care about
us. You know, it might well be the case
that we do not count. I mean, we tend to
think that we are very significant in
the cosmic scheme of things. Uh that's
why we thought at first that we are the
center of the universe. And it took a
while for the Vatican to revise that
view. And uh you know it took 350 years
after Galileo died for them to admit
that he was right.
>> I think it's very interesting that he
brought this up. He said that we used to
feel like we're like the pinnacle of
creation. That man and according to the
Bible, it's true. God created the earth
and he created man as like the crowning
act of creation to have dominion over
the earth, over the animals, over the
garden and all this stuff.
And he says, 'You know, we used to think
we were like the center of the universe,
but you know, Galileo came along and the
church gave him a hard time about that,
but finally 300 years after his death,
they finally revised their beliefs and
now they believe that. So what did they
believe before that? What did they what
did the church, what did the majority of
humanity believe before 300 years before
the death of Galileo? They believed in a
geocentric earth that we were the center
of the universe that the sun revolved
around us that the moon revolved around
us. I think that's very interesting
because that that goes perfectly with
what the Bible says. God made the sun
stop. He made the sun go backwards. It
doesn't say that he made the earth stop
and made the earth revolve backwards.
There's a whole lot of stuff we could
get into that. Um, I'll I'll leave a
link in the video uh in the description
to a video where we talk about some of
that. I'm actually putting together a
presentation on biblical cosmology and
what the Bible actually says about where
we live, why it's important to
understand that, why it helps us to not
fall for the grand illusion that's about
to come upon this earth right now. It's
not some archaic belief. It's not some
distraction. It's not It's truth. The
truth will set you free. Well, this is
what's happening in the news right now.
You know, it says, "Here we go again.
Controversial paper questions whether
interstellar visitor 3i Atlas is
possibly hostile alien tech in the
skies. Possibly hostile alien object
could arrive in November 2025. Wild
research paper says mystery object
spotted in space. Maybe alien spacecraft
coming to attack Earth. Scientists warn
of massive mysterious object may be
surprise attack. Why do you think that
we would be being told for years and
years and years that there's something
coming? The Bible says that Jesus is
coming soon. When he comes, he's going
to destroy the wicked by the brightness
of his coming. If you are not on his
side and you will be caught up to meet
the Lord in the air, you will be
destroyed by the brightness of his
coming. And what does it say? It says
that the elites of the world are hiding
themselves in the cliffs of the rock.
They're going into the caves and they're
so terrified. They say rocks fall on us.
Hide us from the wrath of the lamb.
Why is that? Why are they building these
deep underground military base systems?
The dumbs. These things really exist.
They have two-way byways that trucks can
travel underground way far down,
thousands of feet down. They're growing
rice. They are preparing. They call us,
you know, crazies. If we prep, if you if
you can food or if you uh, you know,
have ammo and have a bugout bag and all
these things, it's all propaganda.
They're trying to prevent you from being
prepared. They're trying to prevent you
from being ready. And actually they can
call you a homeland terrorist if you are
a quote unquote prepper. And these
people are the biggest preppers on
earth. They literally have deep
underground militarybased systems.
Why do we have a space force? Because
Satan is rounding the world together.
Rounding up the militaries of the world
in a preparation in a battle against the
second coming of Christ. Revelation
16:13. I saw three unclean spirits like
frogs. Think of what an alien looks
like. And it says, "For they are the
spirits of devils." So, we know that the
spirits of devils are going to be
working miracles and going forth into
the kings of the earth, the elites of
the world, and the whole world to gather
them to the battle of the great day of
God Almighty. This is prophecy. If you
are a Christian, this is not a
conspiracy theory. This is the truth.
the word of God. Listen to what Jeremy
Corbel said in this TMZ interview. This
was just January of this year. He was
leaking out some things that he knew. He
said, "The big lie that's coming is
they're going to tell you that an alien
is slowly making its way to Earth." And
he said, "They want you to believe this
because they're setting you up for a
lie." Listen to this.
>> And that truth is that UFOs are real.
they've already done told you. Sometimes
when you want somebody to know a truth,
it's so you can set them up to believe a
lie. And that's coming.
I have zero doubt. That lie is coming.
>> What is the lie
>> specifically? You want me to say it
right now for real? Real
on camera to be put in the show?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. problem with that.
If we tell the lie before it's told,
they can adapt.
That wouldn't be wise. I'll tell you
privately, but I would really think
about if you want to put this in your
show for real.
That's a real thing. I'm telling you.
So, will you think about it before
putting it in your show?
>> Absolutely.
>> Okay.
So UFOs are real and they've been here a
long time and that's a truth.
But the lie is coming.
All indications
like all of them
is that that lie is going to be that
there is a craft
slowly making its way to us here on
Earth.
And that is the lie they're going to
want you to believe.
It's nuanced
how they explain that the nature of that
threat.
But that 100% is the lie you are going
to be told. You even got a date. People
been whispering a date for a long time
now. I know where that lie comes from.
I know specifically
what document from the 70s initiated the
idea of that lie. A classified document.
That is the lie you will be told. You're
going to be told that there is a craft
on its way to Earth. That's the lie.
Maybe I'm wrong.
I hope I'm wrong.
I sent you two texts today with a year.
Not from me.
Nope. I'm not going to propagate that
lie. Not going to be part of it. Not
going to say it to the camera. Everybody
knows. Just start paying attention and
they'll change the date. Especially if
they see this. Things will change
because maybe I'm trustworthy. Maybe I'm
worthy of your trust. Maybe I've told
you the truth the whole way through it.
how you can verify it. If that's the
case, then I'm dangerous. You've been
told the truth about UFOs for a long
time now. It's been pretty orchestrated.
It's been pretty clear. And it's using
people that are telling the truth and
want to tell the truth.
Ultimately, they want you to know
something. They want you to know UFOs
are real. Thank God we're finally there.
We're all there now. They want you to
know the truth. But why they want you to
know that truth now?
Hope I'm wrong, but it's terrifying.
Think about it.
Maybe it's good to get ahead of it. Call
it out now before they do it. I'll be
called crazy.
That's okay. This is a Hollywood
filmmaker. He has connections with so
many people and his his main thing is
working with these UFO documentaries and
things like that. And he's saying that
everybody knows that 2027 has been
whispered around. I've heard it from
other people. I I hear this number 2027
come up. You know, Alice Bailey and
Helen Helena Bavotsky, they were talking
about the externalization of the
hierarchy happening in 2025. that that
would be the year of Aquarius, the year
of an awakening, a spiritual shift. But
is something big. Chris Bledsoe said
that on Easter of 2026, something big is
going to happen. Something to do with uh
knowledge increasing in a big way.
Scientists, Harvard scientists, this is
no longer tinfoil hack conspiracy
theorists in the basement. This is the
military just had a US congressional
hearing. Check this out. This was just
today. Look at all this stuff live. It's
live right now. A US congressional
hearing about UFOs with Trump. Like this
is what they're talking about right now.
This is real. That we are being told
that visitors,
unknown visitors, interdimensional. They
say all this stuff. They say
interdimensional beings, we don't know
what they are. that they are coming and
could be here in November of this year.
We're in August, September, October,
November. Three months from now.
They have been giving us a soft
disclosure this whole time for years.
When I made the documentary Disclosed,
this was like three or four years ago.
This is on Little Light Studios. You can
watch it. It's only 35 minutes long.
Very well produced. You can pass it on
to your friends. When I made this
documentary, they were saying, the
military was saying, "Yes, UFOs are
real. We see them every day." That was a
big step because when I was growing up,
it was all explained away. Swamp gas,
weather balloons, all that. Months
later, maybe a year later, they said,
"You know what? We communicate with
nonhuman intelligences." Soft
disclosure. They're not going to come
right out overnight and say, "Oh, aliens
are here." You know, they're telling you
a little bit at a time. I've It's been
happening my whole life. I remember when
the alien autopsy video came out. I
thought that this was a real government
leak that came out and I was I was on to
it and I was like, "Yeah, I want we de
we demand to know the truth. I want to
know the truth. Stop hiding this." It's
all planned. It's all orchestrated. This
is all purposeful misinformation,
disinformation. It's the biggest
psychological operation in human
history. This is literally Satan
deceiving the entire world. Just like
Revelation says that the dragon will
deceive the entire world. How do you
deceive an entire world of different
belief systems, different cultures,
atheists, scientists, Muslims,
Buddhists, all that? You have to deceive
the whole world by saying that you are a
visitant from another world because it
sounds scientific, right? It's not
spiritual. Satan has twisted the
terminology from being an angel to being
an alien. And the world is believing it.
Has been believing it. They're accepting
this. And I've asked people on the
street, "Do you believe in aliens?" Yes.
I said, "If they came and said they had
the answers to our problems, would you
believe them?" 100% of the people that
said they believed in aliens said yes.
Without question, without saying, "Well,
I don't know. We should try and, you
know, question them first." It was just
yes. They said they're smarter than us.
They've been around longer than us. They
have better technology than us. They're
not questioning. They're not testing the
spirits. So, we're in a time right now
of wars and famines and pestilences and
and calamities of all kinds. And they're
already telling us, these Harvard
scientists are saying they may already
be living among us right now. So,
imagine after this little bit of soft
disclosure. Yep, UFOs are real. Yep.
We've been talking to non-human
intelligences. We're having US
congressional hearings all the time
saying this is real. The public needs to
know when they finally come out, which
may be very, very soon, and say, "We
can't hide this any longer. These beings
have been among us this whole time. If
they wanted to hurt us, they would have
already done it. They've been living
among us for thousands of years, and
they've never harmed us. They are only
looking out for us. They are preparing
us for a battle against an evil alien
invader.
That evil alien invader is Christ coming
to earth. And Satan is the one that is
trying to unite the world to side with
him in a battle against Christ. And so
many people are going to fall for this
deception because they think you're
crazy if you say aliens are demons. I've
seen the comment section. They're
saying, "Dude, why would a demon have to
have to fly around in a spaceship?"
Well, why does Jesus come on a white
horse? Why does Ezekiel get or Elijah
get taken up in a chariot of fire? They
are traveling in
crafts of some sort. The thing is is 90%
of the people that actually see these
UFOs are seeing just glowing orbs.
They're not seeing metallic crafts with
nuts and bolts. That's very rare. And
when it happens, I'm sure it's just, you
know, US top secret aircraft.
Why are we not questioning these things?
I want to show two clips from the
disclosed documentary. This was from
Roger Mornau who was a Satan worshipper,
a demon. He was in a demon worshshiping
cult for many years before he became a
Christian. And the high priest was
giving him insight. This this video was
in the '9s. And he said 40 years prior
to this interview, he was told this.
Roger, when I was a teenager back in the
1970s, I remember a song that came out
talking about the age of Aquarius.
>> Mhm.
>> And since then, we've seen the
development of the new age. And I
wondered if back when you were involved
in spirit worship, if they talked about
new age at all.
>> Oh yes. It was a big thing that was
coming up. one of the uh major
deceptions of the last days
and the priest told us uh he had we
talked quite a while and then he said
could I have a bit more your time for
something very fascinating he says the
grain plane the master's grain plane for
harvesting the nations for for
harvesting the multitudes of the earth
into
>> I want you to pay attention to what he's
saying when the new age is on the rise
when we are in the age of Aquarius.
That's where we're at. 2025. That's now.
He said when Satan wants to harvest the
multitudes of the nations, meaning
bringing them together for his
deception.
That's what's coming.
>> His cause just before the close of the
great controversy between the forces of
good and evil. So, we continued, you
know, after we express ourselves that
we're deeply interested to know more
about the activities of spirits. And he
said it's going to be done in a unique
manner.
This this grand plan is is going to take
people people are going to eat the stuff
because he says spirits demon spirits
will
declare themselves to be inhabitants of
far distant planets in the galaxies
that are coming to warn the inhabitants
of planet Earth of the impending
destruction of the planet. unless
something seriously
proper is done.
>> So, they're going to come when there's a
lot of calamity and they're going to
tell the world, "You have to listen to
us. We are smart. We have been watching
you guys destroy yourselves. We can get
rid of all this. We can get rid of
COVID. We can get rid of your climate
change. We can give you free energy. We
can do all that." And we're going to
say, "Yes, please help us." They're
going to be doing lying signs and
wonders. It says, "Miracleworking demons
in the book of Revelation are going to
deceive humanity.
We're going to fall for our senses.
We're going to fall for the tricks, the
lying signs and wonders, and it's going
to look like they're here to help us to
avoid it." And he went on to saying that
they will claim
to have out of body experiences. Are you
familiar with out of body experiences?
>> I've read about In other words, so a
person's uh there some persons are
supposed to be able to you know
they believe in their immortal soul
>> projection. Yes. Right. Goes into
different parts of the world and sees
things and come back and they write all
about it. I have heard of that.
>> So
due to the fact that the millions of the
earth people believe in having people
having an immortal soul.
>> And this is a fact. I I mean we are in a
time right now when I was a teenager
everybody was an atheist. They were like
nope I don't I don't believe in church.
I don't believe in God. I'm an atheist.
I'm going to live what I do. I'm going
to do what I want to do. Live die and
rot in the ground. Now, it's rare to
find an atheist. You find a lot of
people that say, "Look, I'm I'm not
religious, but I'm spiritual and and uh
you know, I I meditate and I believe in
law of attraction and all these things."
You find people that do believe in these
things. The majority of people are
believing in some kind of spirituality.
And most people say, "Oh, when I die,
there's an energy in me that's going to
go on forever." The original lie in the
garden, you shall not surely die. The
majority of the world believes it. The
Bible says that the dragon, the serpent
will deceive the entire world. And most
of the majority of the world believe in
the original lie. We will not surely
die. When we die, we just go on living
somewhere. And we're starting to see it
more and more with DMT and ketamine and
Iawasa and all these out-of- body
experiences. Just like Roger Morno is
saying
>> ready readily accepted when the spirits
will through a trans medium converse
with influential people
>> of the lane you see
>> now what is a trans medium
>> it's a channeler today
>> what what is known today as a channeler
>> channeler yeah
>> okay uh Shelley Mlan's experience of
getting involved in spiritism
and with the u inhabitants inhabitants
of far distant planets in the galaxies I
taped The whole thing is 3 hours
>> and you were hearing the fulfillment of
what this high priest had said 45 years
ago.
>> Yeah. Exactly.
>> Do we see that today? Do we see
influential people that are channeling?
Yeah. I mean some of these uh rock stars
like Devado and Kesha, they are actually
telling you you can meditate and summon
UFOs. You can actually channel
extraterrestrial beings. And these are
the influential people of the world, the
American idols that all the young people
are looking up to right now. Each
generation is going to become more
accepting of what is fed to them over
and over and over from these people that
you can channel visitors from far
distant galaxies which are nothing more
than demons in disguise. So what is
happening? The majority of the world is
believing in spiritualism. They are
worshiping demons. Whether it's through
yoga, whether it's through meditation,
whether it's through channeling, whether
it's just being involved in the occult,
or literally just being in these
churches that are teaching false
doctrine.
They're not believing thus sayeth the
Lord. They're believing what the pastor
says in the pulpit. And they are falling
under the same spell. Everybody's going
to unite together. It's a one world
religion. It's all about peace and
safety. That's what's coming.
Now, here's another clip because
remember what Jeremy Corbel said was
that there's a deception coming. They
want you to believe the lie. The lie
that there is an alien ship coming,
taking its time, and it's coming. He
said, "That's the big lie. The big lie
is that something's coming."
Listen to this clip from Carol Rosen who
was the the speaker for Warner von
Braonn who helped create NASA. He was a
Nazi scientist, rocket scientist. He
helped create NASA and in his last dying
years he hired Carol Rosen to be his
speaker at these conferences. And listen
what he said. Carol Rosen was a partner
and speaker for Warner von Braonn who
was a leading figure in the development
of rocket technology in Nazi Germany.
She said in his last years of life he
started admitting some interesting
things to her.
>> When I was a corporate manager of
Fairchild Industries in 1974 through 77
I met the late Dr. Verer von Brown in
early 74. Von Brown's purpose in life
during the last years of his life, his
dying years, was to educate the public
and decision makers about why
space-based weapons are a dumb,
dangerous, destabilizing, too costly,
unnecessary, unworkable, undesirable
idea. The strategy that Vervon Brown
taught me was that first the Russians
are going to be considered to be the
enemy. In fact, when I met him in ' 74,
they were the enemy, the identified
enemy. We were told that they had killer
satellites. We were told that they were
coming to get us and control us. The
dirty commies, that whole story. First,
the Russians were the enemy against whom
we're going to build space-based
weapons. Then, terrorists would be
identified, and that was soon to follow.
We heard a lot about terrorism.
Then, we were going to identify third
world country crazies. We now call them
nations of concern. But he said that
would be the third enemy against whom we
would be needing to build space-based
weapons. And the next enemy was
asteroids. Now, at this point, he kind
of chuckled the first time he said it.
Asteroids against asteroids were going
to build space-based weapons. So, it was
funny then. And the funniest one of all
was against what he called aliens,
extraterrestrials. That would be the
final card. And over and over and over
during the four years that I knew him
and was giving his speeches for him, he
would bring up that last card. And
remember, Carol, the last card is the
alien card. We're going to have to build
space-based weapons against aliens. And
all of it, he said, is a lie.
>> Do we have space-based weapons?
Absolutely. We have a space force now.
back when she gave this uh little
interview, there was no space force.
Ever since 2020 or 2019 when Trump was
in office, boom, we have a space force
now. We literally have a military branch
that's pointing weapons towards the
heavens. Why?
Because we're preparing to battle
against Christ. And they give us all
this fear propaganda. Oh, there's
asteroids coming. Oh, there's there's
something out there. We don't know what
it is. There's aliens. There's UFOs. And
she said, "And all of it is a lie."
Jeremy Corbel said, "And this big
deception is a lie."
Why is it a lie?
Because Satan is coming as an angel of
light. He's been pushing propaganda
about himself, creating this character
of himself that he is this goat man,
this red with horns and a pitchfork so
that when you see the false Messiah,
when you see him appearing as Christ
himself, you'll fall for it because you
think that Satan is scary and he can
only bring fear and death and misery,
right?
No, he can bring love, right?
He can make you feel ecstasy. He can
make you come out of your body and and
see heaven and fly towards the light. He
can even make you see Jesus himself and
talk to dead loved ones. All these
things make people feel so good. It
can't be the devil. It feels so good.
It's so loving.
I want to show you one thing that I
can't not talk about because this
deception is not only just a deception,
it's an impossibility.
There are no such thing as aliens coming
to earth. And we can see that from the
Bible alone.
And it says that you're going to read
creation. It says in the beginning, God
created the heavens and the earth. And
uh on day one, he created light.
And check this out on day or in verse
six says God said let there be a
firmament a firmament in the midst of
the waters and let it divide the waters
from the waters. So in the beginning
there was nothing but water. The earth
was without form and void. It's all
water. Now suddenly there's this
firmament. What is this word? And God
made the firmament and divided the
waters which were under the firmament
from the waters which were above the
firmament. So whatever this thing is, it
has now divided this waters. Now there's
waters above it and there's waters below
it. And God called the firmament heaven.
All right? So this thing is heaven.
And the evening and the morning were the
second day. And God said, "Let the
waters under the heaven, under the
firmament be gathered together in one
place, and let dry land appear." And it
was so. So now there's water underneath
this firmament with dry land appearing.
And God called the dry land earth, and
the gathering together of the waters
called he seas. And God saw that it was
good. And God said, "Let the earth bring
forth grass and herb yielding seed and
and the fruit trees yielding fruit after
his kind whose seed is in itself upon
the earth." And it was so. The earth
brought forth grass and the evening and
the morning were the of the third day.
And then here in chap uh verse 14 it
says and God said let there be lights in
the firmament of the heaven to divide
the day from the night and let them be
signs
and for seasons and for days and years.
So what are these lights? What are these
lights that tell us if it's day and
night and if it's seasons and years?
This is the sun, moon, and stars. And
where does it say it is? It says it's in
the firmament. Whatever this thing is,
this dividing waters above from the
waters below.
The sun, moon, and stars are in the
firmament called the heavens.
And let them be for lights in the
firmament of the heaven to give light
upon the earth. And it was so. And God
made two great lights. The greater light
to rule the day, that's the sun, and the
lesser light to rule the night. He made
the stars also. So, we're talking about
the sun, moon, and stars, obviously. And
God set them in the firmament of heaven
to give light upon the earth. So, where
are these lights? We know what we just
heard was nothing but water. Firmament
separates. Waters above, waters below.
There's earth under here. And now
there's lights, great lights, a sun, a
moon, and stars in that firmament.
So I want to ask you, what is the
firmament? Some people will say, "Oh,
it's it's the clouds. That's why it's
talking about water." Or, "Oh, it's the
atmosphere. It's our ozone layer."
If you believe that, then you believe
that the sun, the moon, and the stars
are in the clouds or are in the
atmosphere.
But we are told by science textbooks
that the sun is 93 million miles away in
an everexpanding vacuum of space. Tell
me where it's in the Bible. Tell me
where the Bible says that he created and
it's continuing to expand. That there's
a vacuum out there. I'm reading that
above the heavens, this firmament is
nothing but water. That the sun, moon,
and stars are in the firmament.
If there is a glass dome-l like
firmament above us, there is nobody
coming to visit us. There are no aliens
coming to visit us. So people like to
look at this subject and they say this
is divisive like this is a distraction
that you know don't it's not
salvational.
It might not be salvational
but what's coming is a deception that
will cause people to lose their
salvation. The mark of the beast is a
salvation issue. If we fall for alien
visitors or cosmic Christ and one world
religion, then you have taken the mark
because the mark of the beast is not
about a microchip. You can avoid a
microchip at all cost and still receive
the mark of the beast because it's about
the beliefs of your mind and the works
of your hands. Whatever you do with the
works of your hands, do it unto the
Lord. We have to worship him in spirit
and in truth. Trust and obey. Belief and
obedience. You can avoid a microchip at
all costs. God isn't damning people for
microchip implants. I'll never get one
and I I advise nobody ever get one. But
when you're rounded up in the last days
and a microchip is shoved under your
skin, you can guarantee that God is not
going to judge you by that. That a
microchip got jammed under your skin. I
want to show you another verse.
King James Bible
in the book of Job. Strong
looking glass. Some people might not be
fully convinced by these verses yet.
Job 37:18 says, "Ha hast thou with him
spread out the sky." What are we talking
about? The sky
which is strong. The sky is strong.
And as a molten looking glass, the sky
above us, the firm firmament
is like a molten looking glass.
Let's look up the Hebrew concordance
firmament.
I'm going to do a whole presentation on
this guys, but I just feel like I have
to talk about this. Rakia.
What is Rakia? Let's look at the Strongs
real quick. Look at this masculine
surface solid expanse as if beaten out.
This is something that was built like
beaten out like a sheet of metal. The
firmament
by Hebrews as solid and supporting
waters above it.
We're looking at the Hebrew. You have to
erase your mind of what you've been
taught. People are going to say, "Why?
Why would they lie? Why would they lie?
Well, they've already been lying to you,
saying that you came from a monkey. That
you that there was an a magic explosion
of nothingness that created the
perfection of the universe, and you were
an amoeba that appeared out of nowhere,
evolved over millions of years, crawled
out on Earth, and became a human. Do you
believe that? It's in the science
textbooks, and it's being taught all
around the world. Why would they lie?
Because they're hiding God. They're
removing God. Why would they lie about
where we live? again because they're
hiding God and because Satan is the God
of this world and he has a grand plan to
deceive humanity by saying that he's a
visitor from a far distant galaxy that
he's out there from an in a in a vacuum
far far away and he's coming to visit
us. But what does the Bible say? That
there is a very strong moltant looking
glass dome above us that has nothing but
waters above us supporting the waters
above it. When you look at stars inside
of a telescope,
look at what stars really look like.
Does that look like they're flickering
underwater?
The Bible is real. The Bible is the
truth. Let every man be Let every man be
a liar.
God is true. His word is true.
This is truth. The the sun is uh you
know 90 93 million miles away. You know
how you can tell how far light is? If
the sun rays are spled out or if they're
parallel, look at the direction of these
sun rays.
You tell me, is the are are these sun
rays
pointing to 93 million miles away? Now,
people will say
that this is an optical illusion that
these sun rays are actually coming
towards your eyes, but you can follow
the sun rays. Look, these are going down
onto the water back here. These are
going out here. You can look at at the
sun from a plane and you you can see a
hot spot on the earth. You don't see a
hot spot from a light that's far far
away. This is why we see a solar eclipse
because the sun and the moon are equal
in size and distance away. I know this
might be the first time you ever heard
this. I I know this might be a
controversial topic, but this is
important when it comes to this alien
deception because we are being told that
these visitors are little green men and
UFOs from far distant galaxies in an
everexpanding galaxy. God said when he
finished his work, it was complete. Do
you think his creation is still growing
and growing and growing? The
constellations have never changed for
thousands of years. You can simply
search
Hebrew earth. Just type Hebrew earth in
Google and look at the images and you
will see what the Bible teaches about
earth.
This is what earth looks like in the
Bible.
You're not going to find a globe. You're
not going to find a vacuum, an
everexpanding vacuum. You're not going
to find any kind of model where aliens
can come visit.
This is why this is such an important
topic
because millions are going to to going
to be deceived
by visitors from other worlds that are
performing signs and wonders and
miracles. But it's impossible. It's not
just it's not just like, oh, I I
understand it's a deception. It is
impossible.
It cannot be believed when you believe
in the word of God and the word of God
alone. There's a firmament up there. a
dome-like structure. And there are so
many verses that I would love to share
with you guys. But I pray that that was
enough to build your curiosity to say,
you know, I'm going to prove that guy
wrong. I'm going to look this stuff up.
Please do. Please look into it. Look
into the firmament. You tell me what it
is because the sun, moon, and stars are
in there. It says it's a it's like a
beaten out solid structure. If you guys
were blessed by this video, if it was
eye openening, if it was controversial,
if it was shocking, please give it a
thumbs up or a thumbs down. It helps it
get into the algorithm. Please subscribe
to this channel if you haven't. If this
is your first time here, we welcome you.
And if you guys want to support this
channel, we can't do this without you
guys. We if you go to candidtruth.org,
we got Cash App, Vinmo, Zel, PayPal. We
even have Patreon. We also have merch on
our store. I'm actually wearing one of
the shirts right now. Says, "Be cool.
Use your brain." We're bringing smart
back. It's cool to use your brain. And
we can't do this without you guys. We
love you guys. We thank you for your
love and support. We thank you for
watching this. Share this with all your
family and friends because there is a
great deception coming. We are told by
Harvard scientists now that aliens are
coming in November.
Only time will tell, but I do not want
you to be deceived. We love you guys.
We'll see you next time on Can of Truth.